c'est dante inauguration cet après midi
à belfort de la maison de l'information
et du tourisme installé passage de
france sur 500 mètres carrés cette
structure regroupe plusieurs services
dont le but est de répondre aux besoins
d'information de toute personne habitant
belfort ou de passage dans cette ville
vous avez décidé de passer vos grandes
vacances à belfort vous avez mis sur le
nez vous lunettes de soleil mais il
pleut vous commencez à regretter vous
demander ce que vous allez bien pouvoir
faire une bonne adresse la maison de
l'information et du tourisme
l'abeille fort aux thèses charmante et
souriante sur fond de pamiers l'office
du tourisme de belfort souffle un air de
vacances vous y trouverez tous les
conseils utiles plan de la ville hôtels
restaurants
quant aux distractions et ne manquent
pas les nombreux prospectus vente les
mercredis du château la route des fleurs
et les visites guidées de la vieille
ville
les grandes vacances à belfort vous
risquez de ne pas les oublier
vous n'êtes pas vraiment branché mais
vous vous dites qu'il n'est jamais trop
tard pour le devenir
et puis l'informatique c'est vraiment
l'avenir une bonne adresse la maison de
l'information et du tourisme à belfort
elle abrite le centre x2000 ouvert aux
particuliers aux associations aux
entreprises aux établissements scolaires
dépendant de l'université populaire
cette structure permet de jouer et de
créer
on y trouve une grande variété de
matériel et une importante bibliothèque
de logiciels
vous êtes jeune vous passez votre
journée dans les cafés en écoutant les
derniers tubes pour passer le temps très
bien long une bonne adresse
la maison de l'information et du
tourisme à belfort vous serez accueillis
au bureau information jeunesse le bij
ses responsables informent les jeunes de
15 à 30 ans sur l'enseignement la
formation et les métiers la vie pratique
les loisirs
mon sujet on a parlé de cartes jeunes
qui étaient à disposition pour des
jeunes je sais pas de quel âge à quel
âge et je lis savoir est ce que moi j'ai
la possibilité d diawara s'est il avoir
accès à quoi partir de cette cartouche
ah ben voilà alors effectivement ici au
à belfort information jeunesse donc on
prend la carte jeune et au prix de 50
francs le public a aussi à sa
disposition des classeurs des revues des
guides des journaux et un service de
petites annonces
sans oublier le salon télévision pour
regarder les émissions culturelles en
principe mais